[Applause]
in 1958 henry kissinger appeared on a
program called the mike wallace
interview mr wallace questioned mr
kissinger about relations between the
united states and soviet union the
concept of limited war and how to
prevent a nuclear war
it's just under 30 minutes
this is professor henry kissinger a
military and political analyst for the
revolutionary concept of nuclear war
and a constructive concept for peace
he's a man whose ideas have prompted the
highest officials of our government to
re-evaluate our defense policies
we'll get his criticisms of our current
strategies in war and peace
in just a moment
the mike wallace interview presented by
the american broadcasting company in
association with the fund for the
republic brings you a special television
series discussing the problems of
survival and freedom in america
good evening i'm mike wallace
tonight we'll tackle the immediate issue
that will decide the fate of our freedom
certainly and possibly even of our
survival
we'll discuss the conflict between the
united states and the soviet union
and the chances of war our guest
professor henry kissinger
associate director of the center for
international affairs at harvard
university and the man whose recent
proposals substantially influenced
president eisenhower's plan
for military reorganization
dr kissinger last year
your attack on our foreign and military
policies was apparently found so
disturbing that the new york times
carried this front page story they said
for the first time
since president eisenhower took office
officials at the highest government
levels are displaying interest in the
theory of the little or limited war the
theory of massive retaliation is being
re-examined
that was
a year ago
what has come of the re-examination
i think the theory has been re-examined
the practice has not been
the theory has been found wanting then
the theory has been found wanting but i
don't think we have made the effort to
spend the money or made the sacrifice
it's necessary
for
to get a capability for limited war
well now in order to better understand
your proposal for limited war perhaps it
would be well for you to define what you
understand to be
our current
united states military policy what is
our military policy well our current
military policy is based
on the doctrine of massive retaliation
that we threaten an all-out attack on
the soviet union in case the soviet
union
engages in aggression anywhere
this means that against almost any form
of attack
we base our policy on on the threat that
will involve the destruction of all
mankind and this is
too risky
and i think too expensive
you obviously think it's wrong
dangerous to our security i wonder if
you would expand on that just because of
what you say the risk and just because
of the expense it is not worthwhile no
it is what it will mean is that in every
crisis an american president will have
to make the choice whether a given
objective
is worth the destruction of american
cities the american president will have
to decide whether by root
or whatever the issue may be is worth
30 million american lives
in practice i'm afraid the american
president will have to decide that it is
not worth it and it will therefore
encourage piecemeal
the piecemeal taking over of the world
by soviet aggression because you believe
the soviets
understand our
unwillingness or inability certainly our
unwillingness to wage an all-out war the
soviets will understand our increasing
unwillingness to engage in this kind of
war
uh and therefore their task will be to
present us with a challenge which
doesn't ever seem worth taking the final
jump but which the accumulation of which
is going to lead to the destruction
of the free world
in place of that policy what do you
believe our
military political policy should be well
the first thing i'd like to say is that
military policy can't be
a substitute for other measures it can
only be the screen behind which other
measures are possible now with this
qualification i think that we must have
a military capability
that permits us to react to soviet
threats
at the same level of intensity at which
they present it
so that we don't always
have to choose between the destruction
of the united states and the defense of
the countries that may be threatened but
rather that we can defend the areas
which are threatened
at the place where the threat occurs how
is that actually translated into if i
may into more simple language is this
are you simply talking now about a
policy which includes limited war it
it's a policy that yes that we are ready
to engage in limited war that we have
tran troop transports air transport that
gets
enabled us to get into position quickly
and that we have the forces to engage in
limited war which we do not now have can
you give me an example
of how this might actually work out
well at the moment we have 13 divisions
it is clear that with 13 divisions we
are incapable
of resisting soviet attacks when the
soviet union has 175 divisions
if we had more divisions and if we had
air transport
then in case of a soviet attack say on
iraq
we could airlift a few divisions into
the area and together with local forces
attempt a defense
president eisenhower
you advise limited war or you suggest
the the the uh the use of limited war
limited nuclear war indeed president
eisenhower said about two years ago
is that war in our time has become an
anachronism whatever the case in the
past war in the future he said can serve
no useful purpose
a war which became general as any
limited action might he said
could only result in the virtual
destruction of mankind now that's the
rub
it would seem that any limited nuclear
war might boil over into a total war and
so the question is we must put to
ourselves is dare we take the chance
well let me answer this question in two
parts
you say i i advise a policy of limited
nuclear war
i do not advise that we initiate war the
question of war will arise only if the
soviet union attacks
then if the soviet union attacks and in
fact we are
very much more afraid of total war than
they are they will gradually blackmail
the free world into surrender
everything that i say is based on the
assumption that we are as willing to run
risks as the soviet union if this is not
the case
uh we are lost
and i think we ought to face that fact
let's look at some of the measures
let's look at some of the measures which
you propose for keeping a limited war
limited
you say for instance that in the midst
of a limited war
each side could be required to list its
strategic air bases
which would then be immune from attack
all cities within 500 miles of the
battle zone would be immune from nuclear
attack if they were declared open and
certified so to be
it could be proposed that no weapon
larger than 500 kilotons will be
employed unless the enemy uses it first
and so forth
now
two nations which up until now have been
unable to agree on armament control
during peace time
according to dr kissinger are expected
to engage in uh fairly complex
marques of queensberry rules in the
midst of a nuclear ward
it doesn't sound sensible sir i know it
doesn't sound sensible and nor does the
destructiveness of modern weapons sound
very sensible
uh what is required here is a completely
new order of thinking
i hold no particular brief for the
specific limitations which i recommended
what i am saying is this
both sides if they know one thing they
know that an all-out war will mean the
destruction of civilization
of their own as well of the other
they also know
they will therefore have a an interest
in keeping any war that does break out
to the smallest possible proportion
if they are looking for an excuse to
expand it they will expand it
i am assuming they're looking for an
excuse to limit it
what we have to do is to bend our
ingenuity and to find it towards finding
means
to limit
any war that might break out either
through accident or through design
whether these particular limitations are
absolutely the right ones i wouldn't
maintain
but
the great difficulty has been the
traditional military thinkers trained
with
conventional strategy have simply
dismissed
all
new forms of thought and have not
addressed themselves to what seems to me
to be a very real and serious problem
then you think american strategy should
be reevaluated to restore war
as a usable instrument of policy
american strategy has to face the fact
that it may be confronted with war
and that if soviet aggression confronts
us with war and we are unwilling to
resist it will mean the end of our
freedom
we will this is it boils down then to a
value choice in these terms yes i think
war must be made a usable instrument of
policy
let me throw another
argument at you if i may dr kissinger
i'd like to quote from a study that has
been released just a few hours ago
called foreign policy in the free
society written by walter millis and
father john courtney murray
in it
analyst walter millis writes as follows
he says the concept of limited war
presents a simple fallacy in logic
we can resort to limited war he says
only when the objective is not vital to
either side
in which case we would be unlikely to
resort to war in any event as happened
in indochina suez and hungary he's
obviously talking about the united
states when he says we what about that
i
am a great admirer of mr military's i
cannot agree with him there
every one of these instances were
instances where the western position was
eroded
if it is really true that we can never
engage in limited war
while the soviet union can engage in
limited war
uh
i can only repeat that our
expulsion the collapse of the free world
is inevitable
moreover to say that limited war is a
logical fallacy
it doesn't mean very much if you look at
the period from 1945 to 1958
which has had the berlin blockade the
korean war
indochina suez hungary
constant threats of nuclear attacks on
other countries
the fact
cannot be explained away on simply
logical grounds
tell me this sir
suppose the communists were to march
into west berlin next week
would you personally and do you think
the majority of the american people
would want to take a chance on
protecting west berlin
with a limited nuclear war
i am not saying that every soviet attack
must be answered with nuclear war
uh in an attack on west berlin i would
certainly
react in some manner
and in some manner that involves the use
of force
uh
if we do not
no one will ever believe in our
protection again or in our word again
whether the american people would
support this or not will depend to some
extent on their leadership
if you had taken a public opinion poll
on say june 20th 1950
whether the american people would
support uh the defense of korea
you might have gotten an entirely
different answer than the one you had a
week later when the president decided
that it was his end was essential to our
interests to defend it
then i
take it what you envision is if the
government were to follow your point of
view
they should announce
publicly
that from now on
the possibility of limited nuclear war
should uh should be seriously considered
by all americans and by all of our
potential enemies i would announce that
our primary purpose is to avoid war
that if we are forced into war through
soviet aggression we would attempt to
keep it to the smallest proportions
necessary that we would not use more
force than was absolutely necessary
to defend the safety of the free world
but that we would use the amount of
force that was necessary to defend the
free world
as long as we're in the realm of
speculation here let's speculate a
little further what do you think the
reaction of the soviet government would
be to an announcement of that kind
well they would be very likely
to
deny that a war can be limited
because atomic blackmail is one of their
most effective means of expansion
if they can create the impression that
any resistance to soviet aggression
inevitably leads to the destruction of
the country concerned
then many countries will prefer
surrender to defending themselves
if they were faced with a real situation
however
all past experience indicates that this
is not a regime that gambles everything
on one throw of the dice
in the field of foreign policy and
military affairs dr kissinger you're
acknowledged to be one of the most
penetrating minds in the country
last year as i have mentioned you
published a military analysis which
rocked washington
yet you devoted it almost exclusively
to framing a war policy rather than a
peace policy
could this be indicative
of what is happening to our thinking
here in america isn't this indeed what
many of our allies
criticize us for
well i would reject this description of
my book uh
i did not frame a war policy i framed a
policy which i think is the only one
that is going to preserve the peace
i am afraid that
weakness is certainly going to lead us
into a position
where finally we will be forced to
engage in very extreme measures to
defend ourselves
uh i would therefore reject the
description of
my recommendations as a war policy
our problems abroad are more complicated
than this because on the one hand we are
accused of an over emphasis on military
factors
on the other hand the fact of the matter
is that we are not strong enough to
defend most of our allies
and
one of i would at least suggest that one
of the difficulties is that our allies
are both worried about our general
political posture and at the same time
feel that we are not capable of
protecting them
if a showdown comes
what policies let's move from more
policies to positive peace policies
what policies do you believe generally
that we should adopt
to help keep the peace and at the same
time
contain communism well i i hate again
to differ with you but i cannot accept
the distinction between war and peace
policies
defense policies are essential to
maintain the peace
they are not however going to solve the
political problems of the world they are
only going to give us a shield
behind which we can engage in
constructive measures
what is essential right now is that we
identify ourselves with the
tremendous revolution which is sweeping
across the world
that we have some image for the
construction of the free world which is
based on other motives than simply
defending the world against communism
we must make clear what we are for
rather than what we are against
if we were clearer about the kind of
world we want to bring about
if we could project this concern to
other people
then we wouldn't always seem so
intransigently
uh
militant
then we would be identified with
positive measures rather than with
simply military alliance well let's talk
about some specifics
how do you regard our conduct
in regard to the algerian situation of
the past few years
i think the algerian situation is an
extremely
complicated and difficult one
in general we should stand for the
freedom of
people
in general we should oppose
colonial regime
on the other hand we should come up with
ideas which an independent algeria
cannot survive as a purely independent
state the great paradox of this period
is that on the one hand you have a drive
towards more and more sovereign states
on the other hand there is no such thing
as a purely independent state anymore
the thing that has always attracted me
therefore would be that we would
advocate a north african federation
which would be tied together
economically and for other development
projects and that algeria would find its
place as part of that
rather than as a purely independent
state do you
look to the inclusion of nasa and his
peoples
in this north african federation
well initially i would group or i would
recommend grouping tunisia algeria and
morocco
there might be another grouping of
powers in the middle east which includes
egypt
and some of the
states which have had a somewhat
different history than the uh than
algeria would you say that our posture
visa of the egypt has been a realistic
one
do you not agree that the peoples of
africa would seem to respond to nasser
and that we seem to
support governments
in the middle east
which do not always have the support
of their actual inhabitants and that
perhaps nasa has more support than some
of the other governments from the people
themselves well our policy lisa v nasa
has uh has been has suffered from
indecisiveness we have neither been
conciliatory enough when we were
conciliatory nor intransigent enough
when we were in transition
uh we
were not friendly enough to make him
a friend and we were not hostile enough
really to bring him down with the result
that we have suffered from the worst of
both worlds what i'm saying is we have
no policy
that we've been governed by events
and
rather than attempt to shape them i
would think however that even saud does
not represent the force with which we
should be identified in the middle east
let me come back again to the study
called foreign policy in the free
society
in it philosopher scott buchanan says
our problem here in the united states
is to exist as a capitalist society
in possibly
a completely socialist revolutionary
world
now it would seem to a certain extent
anyway that that's the way the world is
going
is it possible that we cannot exist in
such a world
well you know you could argue that the
identification of socialist and
revolutionary is not a very good
identification
you could well argue that
a capitalist society or
what is more interesting to me a free
society
is a more revolutionary
uh
phenomenon than so than 19th century
socialism
and this illustrates precisely one of
our problems i think we should go on the
spiritual offensive in the world
we should identify ourselves with the
revolution we should say that freedom if
it is liberated can achieve many of
these things
well what is keeping us from going on
the spiritual offensive as you see
uh
because we've suddenly been projected
into a situation for which very little
in our history has prepared us and
because i'm afraid many of the
leadership groups that are engaged in
foreign policy
uh have had a set of experience which
make experiences which make it rather
difficult for them
to come to grips with a
really revolutionary situation well now
in that regard earlier this week you
told our reporter that as far as current
leaders are concerned you said
we have an administration of old men
happy with the life they have led
and you considered this dangerous
you smile now what did you mean and why
is it dangerous then why are you smiling
well
uh i made this statement
uh
i think
that the groups i was referring to are
very well meaning very sincere very
patriotic people
the difficulty they have is that
they think that the world in which they
grew up it's the normal world
their tendency is when a crisis arises
to try to smooth it over and then to
wait
and then to expect that the normal
forces would reassert themselves
they therefore they conduct policy
uh a little bit
like
uh oh maybe small town bankers who think
that one can always draw interest
on a good situation
we conduct very often our policies if
arduino would live forever despite the
fact that he's 82 years old
when there's no crisis it's always
very difficult to get agreement on a
constructive step
conversely often requires a crisis to
make us engage in a in in any action
do you see any political leaders in the
united states
you believe have a clear grasp
of america's current place in history
i think one of the very worrisome
features of the situation is that
i don't find
any great moral dynamism on either side
when you say on either side you mean
either a democrat either in the
democratic or in the republican party
how do you account for that dr kissinger
i think we've been
we've been assuming for too long that
all we had to do
but first of all we're a nation of
specialists
we tend to think that a problem is
either economic or political or military
many of your questions earlier in the
program seemed to me to indicate this
when you said
this is a policy of war and that is a
policy of peace
it is hard for us to understand that we
have to be able to do military political
economic and psychological things all
simultaneously
then we
have been rather satisfied with the
situation in our country as it is
and with the world in which we have
lived
our response to the world has usually
been to to an overpowering threat from
abroad
therefore even when we have engaged in
constructive steps like the marshall
plan the greek turkish aid program
which were very great efforts
nevertheless we've always justified them
on the basis of a communist threat
very rarely on the basis of things we
wanted to do because of our intrinsic
dynamism
i believe for example that we reacted
very wrongly to the riots in latin
america
rather than saying these are communist
inspired and we must react to
we must keep latin america from going
communist we should have set this recall
test to our duty these are things we
want to do because of the values we
stand for not because we want to beat
the communists the question the question
is
why
are we as unaware why are we as
unavailing is it because we have been
projected into world leadership in too
much of a hurry unprepared for it is
that one of the reasons it this is one
of one of our very basic reasons is that
we've been projected too much in a hurry
and it must also be said in fairness
that we have done rather well
considering
uh all the challenges that have been
thrown at us it is
too bad that rather well isn't good
enough
another problem is that the people who
emerge in leadership positions in this
country
usually come from a lifetime of
experience which doesn't prepare them
for
to conduct a foreign policy they may
come from business or from law
or even from the universities well
certainly not in the case of john foster
dulles
how would you evaluate the overall
impact of mr dulles on the world
position of the united states
i think that mr dulles is a very
skillful tactician
that he shows extraordinary ingenuity in
escaping from specific crisis situations
unhappily
the real problem in the world at the
moment is to prevent the crisis from
arising
it is to project an image of american
concern and of american purpose this he
is much less successful in doing
he
often gets the impression of being so
infatuated with the
mechanics of foreign policy and
with the negotiation aspect of foreign
policy
that he has
not succeeded in projecting
the deeper things we stand for and often
has created greatly trust abroad
who if any
are the men in public life whom you
admire you personally admire and look to
for leadership for the united states dr
kissinger well i must say first of all
that i'm here as a non-partisan
uh that i'm an independent understood i
i don't stand for either party
in this
uh
this depends uh
i've respected mr stevenson
uh in many of his utterances
respected mr hatches and in many of his
utterances although i've disagreed with
him uh very much
on other things
it's very difficult
for a party out of power to prove what
it can do
but there is no there is no republican
who comes readily to your mind in whom
you have that
that confidence
that that man has an understanding
the understanding that we need to lead
us at this time
i hate to to engage in personalities i i
think that mr nixon in his public
utterances recently has has shown
awareness of the situation but uh
it's i'd rather not deal in in
personalities if you ask me
yes of course we're going to have to
we're going to have to deal in
personalities because
personalities are leaders
and personalities are the people who
eventually have to enunciate
the issues i'm sorry sir but our time
has run out and i'm very grateful to you
for coming here from cambridge to spend
this half hour with us dr kissinger
our survival and freedom of thorny
undertaking at best
become even more difficult to hold on to
in onto in the nuclear age
for this reason we run the danger of
seeking easy answers or of despairing
that there are any answers at all
dr kissinger has suggested a tough
challenging answer part of the answer in
limited war
but as he himself has put it history
will